thank you very much I felt that as
Father's Day is approaching it's
important that we take time to reflect
on how annoying children can be this is
an essay from my book entitled welcome
to playing pasta can I take your order
feeding children is the worst not the
starving ones and distant lands they'd
at least be appreciative I'm talking
about the ones who live in my house it
should be joyful and gratifying when you
make something and feed the ones you
love but when the ones you love are
under three feet tall that is seldom the
case feeding your own children is more
nerve-wracking than cooking for a cranky
New York Times food critic who just had
his car towed my kids don't like
anything they eyeball their plates like
an agent on CSI looking for DNA they see
a speck of pepper and they completely
shut down what's that green thing why is
this different
mom doesn't make it like this I'd like
to see the chef oh you are the chef well
you're fired I honestly don't get it
when I was a kid I was a garbage can
I ate stuff the dog passed up if I
didn't recognize the food I didn't even
ask what it was I just figured it out by
eating it liking it was beside the point
I hated Brussels sprouts but that didn't
stop me from eating them I crammed them
into my mouth washed them down with some
milk and moved on I was just happy that
someone was giving me food maybe that's
why at eight years old I was the same
size I am today
I think we give our children too many
choices my kids walk into the house like
it's Applebee's and immediately ask to
hear about the specials if they don't
like the answer they let me know about
it and if they hear that their sister
does like it they immediately don't I
tried for years to make them happy maybe
they'll like this maybe they'll like
that but nothing worked when I failed to
come up with anything I thought maybe if
we just don't feed them they'll get so
hungry they'll have to eat what we give
them and this could have worked but my
wife doesn't like starving our own
children as much as I do
after all these years I gave up I'm done
trying from now on all they get is plain
pasta it's the only meal that never
disappoints it's nothing but starchy
noodles with virtually no vitamins or
minerals but they eat it every time and
at this point that's all I can ask for
if I had the money and the energy and
knew anything about business I would
open a restaurant and call it plain
pasta do you realize how popular this
restaurant would be called plain pasta
families would be dying to get a table
at plain pasta anyone with a child would
be making reservations months in advance
planning their birthday parties and
ordering takeout how happy would kids be
in a place where plain pasta was the
only item it's tailor-made for them
their parents can't suggest that they
try the scallops or eat a vegetable
because there aren't any there isn't
even a pepper shaker in the place the
parents would be a static too because
they won't have to worry about what to
feed them they could skip ordering
altogether walk in sit down and wham-o a
big bowl of plain pastas slam down
before them like it's feeding time at
the zoo
and by the way this is not to be
confused with my other popular
restaurant chicken fingers oh yeah that
place is a little more down and dirty
there are no utensils of chicken fingers
there aren't even napkins you pick up
your chicken fingers out of a metal
bucket duck dunk them into one of our 12
dipping sauces and wipe your hands off
on your jeans there are chairs for the
adults but not at the tables the parents
didn't lounge chairs around the
outskirts of the room drinking beer and
wine while the kids run around the place
grabbing chicken eating what they want
and throwing the rest at their friends
Oh what sweet irony it would be if I
were to become a millionaire from these
two restaurants for years my kids don't
eat a thing I make and suddenly Here I
am feeding the children of the world Tom
papa
owner of plain pasta and chicken fingers
what a dad
[Applause]
Tom I'll speak for myself having two
kids that was chillingly active
you